what musicians slash bands do you like
do you like the beatles oh yeah i don't
mind the beatles or a few beatles songs
i listen to
a decent amount
eleanor rigby
i like the song called the walrus
recently i've been waking up to of
monsters in men that's my alarm you
oh you you're welcome
if you want to join uh click the link in
the chat
from nightbot and then join
oh okay and now i'll play black widow
oh this game better end before the
tournament starts
okay let's play super super aggressively
f7 is undefended
i might want to do this and this
opponent deliberating
i haven't listened to much k-pop i don't
think i would be able to name a single
k-pop song
[Music]
okay opponents undermining my bishop
well let's
i'm playing the grab polish
looks reasonable
uh maybe this move
usually c4 combines well with a fiance
bishop and now we're we're actually
having a more like binoni-like structure
reminds me of lefong's cat
this actually looks really really
pleasant
because i'm gonna have these like two
squares potentially for both knights
uh
f5 can't be played yet
yeah this looks super
pleasant hi eric
hi
nubin rivaro also hello to
vegan here
two prime subs appreciate that
i feel like black's about to get mated
my castle
and my my king and rooks haven't moved
so i could still legally castle both
ways
the thing is if i castle either way i
got forked on e2
[Music]
so that would probably wouldn't be good
tournament starts in two minutes oh i
might have to simul
wait am i joined i'm joined i might have
to simul chess wi-fi and this current
opponent
the game doesn't end quickly enough
i think g5 looks nice
idea to put the knight here in the vent
of this
yeah this bishop i think when black
played c6 they were focused on my bishop
and not focused on their own bishop
i'm just realizing this bishop is so sad
also b5 looks nice
um i can play this first i guess
bishop's defended
and each file opening does help black
determine starts in one minute
oh my rook's targeted
exactly exchange i could also just oh
[Music]
wait a minute
it's actually a good move
i think i'll just play rook f1
oh but then knight g5
if i play this
looking at knight f4 bishop f3
i think it's okay thank you aza
and robert e gifting to
someone
oh
okay i guess we're going into this line
f7 is going to be a target nine
no
no stop counting six
five okay it's about to happen three
times two one score zero
okay i'm gonna use all my time
ah
okay
i usually i'm good enough to avoid
giving simuls but
uh
my loud down
[Music]
better
this is reasonable oh it's not flag
okay
it's just for this first game
the rest of the game should be
less
intensive
oh chess wi-fi wants revenge too from
the previous debacle
and this position is already
uncomfortable
this position is good though
uh
i don't like it when it's my move on
both boards
let's bring in my knight
oh this is a free pawn
looks like a free pawn
[Music]
h
oh there's a bishop on d1
let's bring the knight in
f4
okay i gotta focus on this game
um
it's slightly annoying
i defend
okay
[Music]
oh no i'm in trouble
where am i
i'm alive
and queen g8 id on the end
there we go
don't hurt me
there we go
no no
let's go okay
oh what just happened there okay now now
i have a less than a minute left in this
game what is this
uh i gained some rating
if i refresh this game will my reading
update
i feel like this is a weird edge case
so it says plus 17 here
um
let's refresh
2143 oh it still shows the same reading
i wonder what happens to my reading now
i'll find out soon enough
okay i gotta win this game first
let's uh push some pawns
ah wait
oh that's a good move
okay
[Music]
oh no i'm worse here
[Music]
there's still some small tricks
ah
oh no my sub oh yes your sub
oh no my time and position
11 seconds here
slightly uncomfortable
uh
to put the bishop in
trying to calculate it's so hard to
calculate though
oh maybe it's not
wow
i think maybe did white intend to take
the pawn
i really should have flagged that game
what just happened there
also there was bishop f1 after bishop f1
i was gonna play e3
i wasn't sure what was happening i think
it might be a draw
there's queen b one more 960 symbols
dear supreme leader
oh yeah i don't know if i want to do too
many
cause me gray hairs
who's meeting in five oh oh this is
winning for black oh wow
oh it's already oh so it's winning after
queen f3
i'm not sure if i would have been able
to convert with four seconds
okay back to tournaments wow wow are we
content please that was awesome
i'm glad you like that
that's maybe going to be the start to
whatever youtube video this turns into
but now we're going to have just single
games
just just960 let's try and play a gambit
like every game
starting with
it's hard to sack upon on the first move
okay i'm gonna play super aggressively
the rest of the games is tournament
uh which involves okay
pushing random pawns so this is my
gambit
wow it's not accepting it
please accept it
so the point in stacking upon like this
i'm just trying to accelerate my
development
and
if white gets too greedy then maybe i
can
like bite back
play g6
rules to activate the queen
some pressure against c2
in the knight defends but uh
okay white's being extra safe here
so
yeah i can still legally castle both
ways
wow so white legally castles
now i want to target the king
hmm oh it's playing very safe
but that doesn't stop me from attacking
so now if i castle i get forked
uh
this pawn's also attacked
so i guess this defends this and this
and pretty soon i'll probably end up
crossing queens or kingside
even though this is long castling
[Music]
and bishops are staring at each other
wait this is a free
knight
yeah i think my opponent just blundered
there
and now i'm up at night
still a lot of attacking potential too
um move back
so the main goals are to target the
the weak dark squares
i play this or this
i think i'll play it anyway
i'm looking at rook f1 knight t4
which looks kind of sus
but i don't see anything wrong with it
here here i take with queen
how much do i need to donate for you to
grow your hair out for six months
i did promise if i
if we hit ten thousand
ten thousand ten thousand subs on twitch
uh then i'll perm my hair
which would require growing it out for
probably about six months
so i guess you could do the math
but
i think the longest i've gone without a
haircut
is maybe like three or four months
it's actually probably some time around
pandemic like i i just
avoided getting a haircut
for probably about four months
thank you muchacho
castle
i think castling really does much
let's move the queen out of danger
whoa it's like a delicazelle
okay one step closer to ten thousand
subs and perming my hair
okay
oh no
am i in trouble
[Music]
wait what did i do here
work f8
i'm in trouble
it's not the end of the world it's just
i'm losing the back material
i guess i could play this
and i'll lose exchange
it's still probably preferable for black
although there's this move coming
[Music]
that move doesn't scare me as much
so idea to put the knight on c5
this bishop is really sad though
this pawn is also kind of lonely
i think i'll just focus on activity
try and get the rook in
it's important to keep the time
advantage
i'm holding on to the pawn
okay plenty of time what are the odds
white gets forked
this was pretty high okay
good game though uh opponent fought back
well like i
i won a piece and then all of a sudden
there's d5 and i was in trouble kind of
okay
back to tournament
top ten
oh locker guy doing well
playing alireza
not the real alareza but maybe close
enough
okay uh
let's play something aggressive
so almost all the pawns are defended
except this one
[Music]
so i'm just playing super aggressively
i'm trying to go straight for the throat
i queen my knight they're coordinating
uh now i can play
even play this move
i'm just gonna throw pawns at black
maybe i'll try and win connect eight
that's actually a decent move though
that's a very decent move let's play g5
now if takes takes takes i fork
hey
it's who is molina
wait who is
who is melina
does anyone know who molina is
thanks for the raid i haven't heard of
that name before
uh i really appreciate it oh no
i just wondered
if you're just joining this is chess
960.
it's a different type of chess
where pieces are scattered or set up
randomly on the
the
first and last rank
uh
the thing is i can take taken bishop d4
and hold on to everything
which
let's do that
also queen oh queen here
if d6 queen e4 bishop d4
and i'm surviving
oh molina is best friend of alexandria
beautes
oh that's kind
well shout out to who is molina
yeah i really appreciate the raid um i
am running a viewer tournament
for chess 960 so if anyone wants to
get involved and get dirty
link is in the chat
and thankfully
like i thought i blundered but now i'm
just recovering
avoiding blundering this rook
currently up a night
i'm gonna try and be sneaky here
just set up some mating ideas
oh
[Music]
not quite mating though
it's close
check
maybe a4 first
so the bishop defends the rook from afar
um so there's this resource
there's this resource
there's this move
too many choices
i think i'll play this move because if
queen takes bishop i made into
otherwise okay my king is
relatively safe
oh thank you to linga shark
where's my
where's my win
hi eric
best spots for tea in the quay
oh in the central west end um
there's really not too many like
tea specific spots
there's somewhere near the pie pizzeria
which i haven't actually explored
um
i mean probably my apartment
is the best spot for tea
let's wait where's my thing
play this move no
play
this is frustrating that i'm not like
winning quickly
okay let's play this and go for the rook
check
like these pieces are a bit awkward it's
a bishop e6 i check
and then it looks like it's force mating
there we go
i guess i could have taken that but
am i not meeting
it's really close
okay so something blocks i check
queen ca coming
in d8
this king is so slippery
someone doused it in oil
where's my mate
okay i'm going to the corner for the
lulls
here's my mate there we go okay
from corner to fiance square
i'm sure i missed something like sooner
but
okay that worked out
yeah i mean there's starbucks starbucks
is across the street from the chess club
oh playing doctor boom boom christine
who's probably underrated
has a very high puzzle rating i'm
ambiting
[Music]
uh okay let's play aggressively
or let's play a london
not too many chances to play a london in
chess 960.
oh thank you loon
loonji pp
let's play yeah london time
but this will be more aggressive than
normal
actually i could play joe bava london
and i'm going to go straight for the
throat again
realizing my g pawn is pinned okay let's
be super aggressive
it actually reminds me the the one time
i played carlson in chess 960
i think i played most of these moves
yeah so with the pawn committing to a5
black can never play a6
and i'm not too concerned about c6
because that would block the bishop
and open the diagonal more
e5 is a playable move though
oh no
i didn't have too many choices there but
this bishop is going to be sad for a bit
while i post this to youtube that's the
plan
uh because the tournament started very
interestingly
for those maybe just joining
i started the tournament having to give
a symbol because i was in the midst of a
game
uh a new one started oh i miss that move
of this move
so my goal is to castle kingside
long castle
and then just go crazy on the queen side
like throw all the pawns
i was so satisfying to drag the king all
the way over
my minor pieces protect the king
although if the knight lands here it's
mother mate so i have to be careful
okay c4 i mean c4 c5 is like the
ultimate way to
oh black castle 2
[Music]
i was going to say the ultimate way to
chisel away at the structure
but requires more patience now because
now i'm pinned
yeah i want to play this maybe g4
i have this move too
[Music]
so if queen here i have c5 d5
not entirely sure what's going on
there's also f4 to consider
oh it's confusing
c5 d5
i have a funny idea
it doesn't work though
but maybe it works okay let's start with
this my idea is to play e4
it probably doesn't work
oh king g7
another idea is to take and then go in
here
which looks kind of cool
[Music]
maybe i'll start with this
now there's d5
c6 incoming also 96 incoming
yeah probably 96 first so if here
there's this
now my pawn's going to hang in the end
c7 is kind of hanging oh it's getting
wild what is this
okay let's take c7 defending e6 again
move back
okay let's move back and go into d5
uh
what do i do here
is this move
to control the d
file good move
actually a difficult position not
material
you trade
for this
hitting the queen
oh the i thought the bishop was
attacking my rep but it's not
let's play g4 unleashing my light
squared bishop finally
g5
still a very tense position
down a little bit of time
those bishops unleashed
[Music]
this is terrifying now
[Music]
hipaa t hopper t he petty hopperty
fishes go floppity and the horses go
cloppety i don't have time for your
rhymes
but thanks for the rhyme
no
ah good game
oh floppity hippity
saddy
ah okay good game dr boomkinstein
okay
so now it's time to tilt
i i was hoping to make a run to win this
viewer tournament but
um
i think in order to do that i need to
like berserk tilt the rest of my games
also thank you madang subbing for 10
months
what was that
oh that was michael hoffman with the
hippity hoppity
yeah i was almost inspired to
hippity-hoppity with my pieces but
okay too late now let's play b5
oh i could play in england
england gabba time
this is full tilt
does the trap the trap doesn't work for
multiple reasons
actually it could like it could be funny
with the d-file alignment
white's not allowing any funny business
okay so i'm leaving this pawn hanging
which is my gambit for the game
i might as well take this
let's defend
bishop looks really pointless here
but
another diagonal to work with
so f7 could be a problem square
white's playing safe
i'm trying to play aggressively here
c5 incoming
that's a good move
oh
let's play d6 and develop the knight
wait what
we just sacked a knight for a pawn
so white was playing safe for a while
but all of a sudden is going full aggro
um i think my king's finding safety here
though
and e5 is really well supported which is
important
also f3 is covered so
uh yeah on passant
and i have one two three
attackers
one only has two
things
okay
so basically winning more material
oh did my opponent think it was three
check
they did go out of their way to check me
now i'm going to go out of my way to
checkmate white
so i'm threatening this this and then
double checkmate
i don't think uh
i don't think white's going to survive
too much longer
yeah it's a party on the king's side
and these pieces are not invited
ah
my mouse didn't want to play rook g2 but
okay
back to tournament so i'm trying to
catch up
okay he's working d4
i think for the rest of the tournament
i'll just move a center pawn without
even like acknowledging the setup
because usually controlling the center
is a good principle
[Music]
let's play a queen's gambit
but not really a gambit
g7 is a bit tender
you might want to develop my bishop at
some point
black's already being aggressive
i'm trying to be aggressive too
pinning the pawn
if bishop seven i play this and hit the
bishop
if bishop here i play h4
and there's a funny line h5 takes takes
never mind
taken maybe with a pawn but let's
improve the bishop first
castle
[Music]
this move hitting this getting out of
the pin and also threading this
that's a good move which i kind of
missed
okay so we trade
my knight wants to be here
let's go there
okay that worked out nicely
worked out really nicely
oh i'm not quite winning yet
i did just win a decent amount of
material for the queen
or decent uh
[Music]
it was a decent trade for me
i just have to move faster
yeah black has two knights for queen and
pawn
move quickly here
i think i want a minority attack
just to open more files
if i need to take take and then fork the
pawns
okay now i just want to go in for the
kill
king here maybe bishop d6
okay threading the pawn
turning the rook
okay at this point i'm just trying to
clean up
oh there goes my queen
plenty of time
[Music]
okay
oh let's let's admire the mate though
uh
that was a nice mate
i'm just trying not to waste time
yeah nice uh center me
okay
uh let's go oh playing udai again
uh
play this move
i'll push the center pawn
oh my knight is a bit stuck
okay i want to play this
i'm trying to win quickly here
or at least move quickly
that's a good move though okay let's
take
oh no
ah
oh no my position's crumbling
to play that move
try and cut my losses
idea this and mate
yes okay let's go
i'm treating every blunder as a gambit
so i'm within range there's 11 minutes
and some change left
um
oh locker guy is
leading i've lost one game but now i'm
on a berserking streak
playing something something
pick a dag
let's play
i can't play stafford let's play
whatever this is
this is uh
it's weird i'm kind of realizing this
i've realized this before but chess 960
it just takes more mental energy
because in normal chess i can kind of
just rely on previous knowledge for the
openings
but chess 960 i have to be like
constantly alert from the very start of
the game
um
i can't just like rattle off the first
dozen or so moves
having like studied the position before
i can still play quickly it's just uh
not quite the same thing
so this pawn's kind of a target
this is going to be tender at some point
oh no my bishop
wow okay so white's not taking it white
could have taken that plate knight here
to block the thing
but white's being careful
respect for that let's take and play
this
i'm just trying to be hyper hyper
aggressive
okay
yeah i think it was probably still good
for white to take because i would have
ran out of fuel at some point but
white's just trying to be solid and
probably trying to flag me
let's activate my knights
some idea b5 before
now the bishop's trapped
that worked out nicely
now i'm threatening rook b3
this b4 i probably just sack
if knight takes
making now this move
so if takes i take on c2 and then win c3
if takes here
i didn't calculate this fully
but white's not taking my stuff
move back
running the pork
of greatness
keep queens on the board
that's not quite winning oh this is a
funny move oh no my queen
okay that was a nice mate no time to
waste
oh fourth place
so within one win of catching first
probably time for at least two more
games
trying to make a miracle here
okay e4
best buy test
king's gambit time
uh
no time to think about how things
interact with each other i just want to
attack g7 never mind
let's develop a bishop
i should castle soon or maybe attack a
pawn
attack another pawn
oh no my pawn is kind of hanging
it's still hanging
sometimes hard to see the long distance
queen moves
[Music]
slightly unusual
structure here
and black's a bit restricted like this
polymer restricts the knight the queen
restricts the bishop
that's a good move play this move this i
play this
okay let's lift some
rooks and get swole
okay let's take c3
some idea rookie 6.
another idea bishop g6 which looks kind
of clever
oh no my bishop
now let's lift another rook
oh wow is my thing trapped
i think it's kind of trapped
i want to sack and then mate eventually
but it's not so clear
it's a fun looking position though i
have full light square domination
[Music]
my might use this and
[Music]
eventually checkmate
probably bishop h6
yeah this is looking really good because
it takes it's made into
otherwise i play work h4 and then
there's gonna be discovery mates
wow locker guide has 33
on fire
they're threatening
multiple mates
okay back to tournament
i'm still within range i need to get one
more game in
playing the bag man
okay opening trap
i win a pawn and the exchange
that's nice
if white tries to do the same i just
developed my knights
so this this game will finish before the
tournaments
the hope is to have even one more game
after this
some targeting
going in both directions though
i'll play this move
okay so i'm kind of losing a pawn
but i'm not getting mated threatening
mate and fork in this move
let's go
okay let's go a quick win there
wow
locker guide won another game berserking
so i need to i need to get one more game
in
i don't know if i'll have time for one
more game
i gotta play super super aggressively
good job locker guide
having a fire tournament
ah no game is starting no one wants to
play me okay here
please play this move
that's too much to ask for though
oh
i think i'll go further
oh wow okay let's play this
i'm just going straight for the throat
this game
this could backfire a lot but it's
interesting
also front fire
here's my mate
oh there's something funny on facade
more like on poisson check
i'm calculating a funny line here here
here here here
oh that's not even on poisson never mind
okay
let's get moving
yeah the problem is there's not enough
tournament time left
my opponent could run the clock down but
hopefully that doesn't happen
[Music]
it's already like
almost meeting
[Music]
of this i think i just take with pawn
king here i take and win the queen
can hear
there we go
let's go
pairing's closed
is locker guy playing
locker ride is playing
oh it might be close
it might be kind of close but there's
oh they drew
oh no
i don't think i won the tournament or
did i
maybe i did
did we tie
the pairings are closed
oh i won on tie breaks oh good
tournaments
oh wow that was a clever draw at the end
to get the extra tournament point though
everyone's saying i miss smothered mate
are you guys trolling me or did i
actually miss some other mates
wait
oh i miss mother mate oh
i was so excited to double white spawns
i miss maiden one
i was so fixated on the potential for
knight h3
oh no
well it still works out
i guess i didn't deserve a tournament
victory for
i was a fork mate too i've been so nice
uh well thanks everyone for playing got
some nice music
confetti
thank you michael hoffman
w dollars
oh yeah thanks for doubling my dollars
in addition to the hippity floppity
flippity [ __ ] oh no my smothermate
yeah
also yeah big big
kudos to locker guide for
like leading most of the tournaments
um beat me earlier like before the
tournament two
got over 200 players playing yeah i
appreciate the turnout
um i don't usually do too many like
chess 960
dedicated streams
but if this goes on youtube
uh hello to youtube people
let me know in the comments if you've
made it this far and also let me know
your favorite chess variant in the
comments or in the twitch chat
and then i'll maybe try and mix in some
more variants
in the coming streams